[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHESTER LUI: So welcome,
everybody, to today's session.
We're really excited
today to be talking
about taking a look at some
of the biggest challenges
that we're currently
facing in business today,
particularly as you make
a shift to the cloud.
My name's Chester.
I actually lead Chrome
Customer Engineering Team.
And I've been here at Google
for going on six years.
I'd also like to
introduce Daniel McClure.
Daniel, if you can just
stand up for a moment.
He's going to be
presenting alongside later
to talk about Warby Parker
and how they're currently
leveraging Chrome Enterprise
in their corporate offices,
as well as the
retail slides today.
So with that, let's get started.
So let's take a look today.
I think many of you are
familiar with the current threat
landscape today.
It's actually quite
different from the way
that it looked a few years ago.
In fact, the very nature
of the forces plays
have actually shifted.
Threats no longer originate
from rogue actors.
And what we mean by
that is we now actually
have well-funded
organizations that actually
have organized attacks.
So that's why we're seeing so
many of these familiar attacks,
whether it's phishing, malware,
social engineering, all of this
is increasing, not
only in volume but also
in sophistication.
So what does that mean?
The growing amount spent
on information security
globally has been
unable to put a stop
to the rising number of
cybersecurity breaches
year over year.
In fact, this year, the
security information market
is forecasted to
actually grow nearly 9%,
totaling $124 billion.
And the number of targeted
breaches in the US
is growing at a rate
of 27% per year.
So what do we do?
This clearly is not
a winning formula
And so if we're investing more
to address the same problems
but at the same time
the number of incidents
continue to increase, then
there is a clear and painful
disconnect.
This is not going to end well.
Simply throwing
money at this problem
is not going to solve it.
So let's take a look at our
current endpoint strategy.
To combat these actual risks,
organizations are ultimately
seeking endpoint
devices that use
an OS with an embedded
security module, one
that is inherently resistant
to viruses, as well as malware,
by design.
This enables automatic
support for safety measures,
such as two factor
authentication, smart card
readers, and many more
security features.
So I want you all to think
about your endpoint computing
strategy.
And here's why.
So let's think for
a moment in time,
instead of managing an entire
fleet of inherently at risk
endpoint devices, I
want you all to think
about how you can actually
control the threat by moving
that endpoint to the cloud.
And you can do this by using
an actual secure cloud native
solution like Chrome Enterprise.
Chrome devices as well as Chrome
browser are secure by design.
They deter end users
from falling hostage
to harmful attacks.
And in the event that
one actually prevails,
it actually
mitigates the impact.
So let's talk about what we mean
when I say secure by design.
Chrome devices are
designed from the inception
to be fundamentally different.
It's a different platform,
different operating system.
They're not created by
simply throwing together
an OS on a generic
commoditized motherboard
or a piece of hardware.
And so what we mean
by that is regardless
of which OEM manufacturer
that you select,
whether it be HP,
Samsung, Asus, et cetera,
they all build to designs that
are architected by Google.
So we dictate the
reference design
that we use to different
OEMs of choice.
And with the specific
hardware components
that are engineered
to work, they
work together in sync
with the operating system
and vise versa.
So each layer of the
machine you're working with
works in conjunction
with others in a way that
provides a unique and ultimately
a very secure environment.
So when you start using
Chrome devices at work,
your work is ultimately
stored safely in the cloud.
Now given the nature
of the situation,
some files, whether
it's your user
data, your downloaded files,
your cookies, your cache, et
cetera, they need to be
present on the actual device,
for example.
Chromebooks natively
encrypt this data,
leveraging a built-in
Google security module.
In fact, encryption is enabled
by default on a Chromebook
and can not be disabled.
This is regardless of anybody
that uses that device.
The hardware has a
tamper-resistant security
module built in.
And this is on
every Chrome device
that's manufactured today.
So the security hardware
does more than just
ultimately encrypt
the actual data.
It performs a multitude of
tasks to prevent software
and firmware version rollbacks.
It provides tamper evidence.
And a good example
of that is someone
that actually tries to
swap the hardware out,
like a hard drive, with a
different piece of hardware
Additionally, there
are hardware components
that serve to protect
the OS tampering.
All Chromebooks use something
called verified boot,
if you're not
familiar with that.
A verified boot confirms
that the operating system
is authentic, safe, and
is Google-distributed
in leveraging a build.
You can not boot a
corrupted version
of the operating system.
In fact, there's
actually two versions
of the operating system on
the device at all times.
Through the verified
boot process,
if the OS is found
to be corrupted,
it can switch to the
ultimately the second version
of the operating system, which
provides the verified boot
check.
And additionally, having another
version of the OS automatically
means that you can update
the background procedure
for the operating system without
interrupting the actual user's
work.
So by having two versions
of the operating system,
you can do updates
in the background,
and you can ultimately
update the actual device
during the session
which a user is using.
There are other
benefits to having
an actual small footprint
of data on the device.
First off, Chromebooks are
cloud native by design.
So unlike traditional laptops,
your files and your data
are primarily
stored in the cloud.
Chromebooks can be set up
in an ephemeral fashion.
So for those of you that don't
know what ephemeral means,
this means that all user data is
wiped clean after each session,
whether you can set
a timer, you can
wipe the device after a
user selects the sign out
or exit option.
With Chrome devices, your
data is kept inaccessible,
it's kept offline, and it's
ultimately kept secure.
Furthermore, let's take a
look with Chrome devices,
there is no longer this
need to continually attend
to update releases and patches.
For anything, as I previously
mentioned, updates to Chrome
occur in the background
without direct interaction
on behalf of the user.
So we're ultimately
as an administrative,
we're not pestering or
nagging the user with all
of these pop ups and reminders.
Administrators can
rest assured easily
manage their fleet of
Chrome enterprise devices
and ensure that they
have the most up to date
and secure version of
the operating system
in their fleet of machines.
It's important to
ultimately note
that Chrome is in a constant
state of improvement.
And with continual bug
fixes, security enhancements,
and feature rollouts
on a frequent basis,
we keep abreast of the current
threat landscape that occurs
on Chrome Enterprise today.
Chrome comes with the option
of leveraging Google's Safe
Browsing service.
This is the same service that's
available on the consumer
side of things.
But on the Enterprise
side, what we do
is Google indexes over
trillions of websites
and maintains a
database of sites
that are known or
suspected to be malicious.
In the event that there
is a malicious site,
we'll alert the user
about the actual site.
And we'll actually give the
option to proceed or not.
Administrators actually
from Enterprise
enrolled devices
have the ability
to prevent users from going
to those sites altogether.
So this notion of leveraging
Google's scope and scale has
helped kept malicious
apps off devices,
which is present in many
of the aspect features
that we offer today from a
Chrome Enterprise perspective.
So Chrome offers a multitude
of Enterprise applications.
So if you take a look at
all the different ways
to extend beyond the browser,
some of the native features
with Chrome browser include
the ability to, let's say,
run a customized Google
Play Store front.
A lot of enterprises
want these features.
In addition to
that, you can also
access legacy applications, such
as VDI Solutions from partners
like Citrix, as well as VMware.
While still others can run
using Chrome's native ability,
we also have the ability
to run Android and Linux
applications on many other
types of devices as well.
So Chrome browser has long used
sandboxing to actually contain
threats with browser
tabs Chrome apps
and the overall Chrome
browser process.
Chromebooks takes this
to an actual further step
by ensuring that all Android,
Linux, and OS processes
are kept separate and
contained from each other.
So Google recently
actually introduced
site isolation, which provides
additional protection, making
it even harder for
untrustworthy websites
to access or steal information
from your accounts,
as well as other sites.
So now with all those extensions
that you run on Chrome,
how do we actually know
that we're actually
vetting and securing
these actual extensions?
So what Google does
behind the scenes
is we constantly enforce
a rigorous control
on what's available in the
Chrome Web Store today.
We implement processes such as
extension reviews, both manual
as well as automated.
Some of these might include
fingerprint analysis,
reputation analysis.
And we also have added a new
feature which no longer accepts
obfuscated JavaScript files.
So let's take a look at
the management policies.
Chrome provides
admins the ability
to enforce very, very
granular controls.
These controls offer
administrators exactly what
they can and cannot enforce
to be installed and run
on a Chromebook.
As an admin, I can dictate
which policies and app or apps
can be permitted
to be installed,
which are automatically
installed,
which apps can be also
force installed and pinned
to the toolbar.
I can also blacklist apps which
can be forbidden altogether.
This extends
further to determine
which sites can perform what
actions or even prevents users
from visiting specific sites.
Lastly, if you enter your
corporate password on a site
that isn't corporate-owned--
we actually use this
at Google today--
but you'll actually
get a notification
that your password was
used on a third party site.
This is a new feature, which
eliminates potential phishing
usage by tricking a
user into entering
their corporate
credentials on a site that
might appear to be legitimate.
Now let's talk about
Google Play Protect.
So Play Protect scans all
the apps in the app store
by leveraging our AI fed
billions of data points.
We look at everything
from pinpointing
where to look to which results
in a very low number of PHA,
or Potentially Harmful Apps.
So Play Protect also utilizes
something called attestation.
This is a SafetyNET
Attestation API.
It provides app
developers the ability
to determine if their
app is actually running
on a genuine Android platform.
And ultimately,
developers can also
use the Verify
Apps APIs to query
the status of Play
Protect for mitigation
as well as remediation.
So let's take a look at how all
of these pieces come together
and work together, which
ensures that we protect
the users and their data,
as well as your data
and how we keep you safe.
So here's a common
attack for phishing.
In this scenario,
a phishing attacker
will conduct research by
gathering information,
let's say, about your
corporate employees.
They might even craft a
highly targeted email,
tricking employees and
users into thinking, hey,
this is a legitimate message.
Employees are scammed
into downloading
malicious attachments.
They might even give
up their password
or share sensitive data.
So how do we address this by
stopping the actual scams?
We do actually three
things on the platform.
First off, if you're
leveraging Gmail,
we use machine learning to
identify phishing emails
and prevent them from
reaching inboxes altogether.
But let's say you're
not using Gmail.
Chrome warns employees
before clicking
on suspicious links that leads
to dangerous actual sites
Additionally, security
keys help prevent hackers
from using stolen passwords
to access employee accounts.
Real quick question.
I probably won't be able
to see you all here.
But quick show of hands,
how many folks out there
are actually using hardware
security keys today?
Very few.
So let's take a look at an
actual second common attack,
ransomware.
I think many of you
are familiar with this.
With ransomware, things
are a bit different.
Ransomware is designed to block
access to a computer system
until a sum of money is paid.
So out of the gate,
I want you all
to remember that the Chromebook
data model limits the data that
can be held at ransom
since very, very little,
if anything is designed to be
on the device to begin with.
And what we mean by
that additionally
is that executables, MSI
files, they can't be installed,
they can't run.
They can't run locally plain
and simple on a Chromebook.
We talked a good deal about
malicious applications earlier.
And just a bit ago, we
even discussed the security
and protection controls that
we use in Google Play as well
as the Chrome Web Store.
And I want to
highlight that even
in the unlikely event of an
exploit, the scope is contained
and its impact limited by
Chrome's inherent sandboxing
model.
Here's a really
interesting question
that I get all the time.
The question that comes up is,
why do I not need antivirus
on my Chromebook device?
So a quick explanation of
this is much conventional
wisdom has led us
to the conclusion
that in order to
secure our devices,
we need to basically
have a stack of product
to assist with securing
that actual device.
If your genuine interest is in
keeping your operating systems
virus free, I think that they
ask and what we've done here
is design one in
which viruses can not
install on themselves
to begin with,
which is exactly
what Chrome OS is.
Not only does this result in
inherently more secure devices
by design, but it saves you a
boatload of virus protection
subscription licenses overall.
And of course, because the
threat landscape is very, very
dynamic, continually evolving
and changing, it's critical,
I think, for all of us to
keep our devices in your fleet
as current as possible.
So as we discussed
earlier, the background
updating capability
of Chrome OS ensures
that this happens
seamlessly, it happens
without any direct
interaction, and it
happens on behalf
of the end user,
because administrators
have the ability
to dictate when this
actually happens.
This gives everybody
in the enterprise
the maximum amount of protection
with minimal, if any effort.
And with that, I'd like
to welcome Daniel McClure
from Warby Parker on the stage.
DANIEL MCCLURE: Good
afternoon, everybody.
As Chester mentioned,
I'm Daniel McClure,
manager of tech services I've
been with the company for five
years now.
I just celebrated my five
year anniversary on Sunday.
So technology
services is the team
that's responsible
for managing the users
and devices across two corporate
locations, one in New York City
and one in Nashville, a
manufacturing facility
that's about an hour
and a half north
of New York City where
we actually cut and pop
our lenses into frames.
And then we are close to 100
retail locations as of today.
So right now, the landscape
looks like about 2,000 users,
3,500 different
endpoint devices,
225 internet connections
that are all trying
to be down as much as possible.
And I have a team of
five support engineers.
So one of the reasons
that I've been
able to keep such a
lean, efficient team
is that over the
past five years.
I've tried to ingrain a
culture of self-service,
really empowering the
end user using anything
I can grab from my
toolkit to really leverage
and remove any kind of
blockers that the typical IT
manager would see,
anything like I
don't have admin
access on my computer,
I need access to more services,
I need my accounts unlocked
and my passwords reset.
So again, really pushing
a lot of the work
back onto the user to kind
of remove IT as a blocker
from getting things done.
So I never wanted to
be an IT team that
is an impedance to work.
I want to help push
people into the future.
The problem with this
is that as we push users
into a more self-service
and user empowering model,
we have to do so very
thoughtfully to make sure
that we're striking just that
perfect balance between user
experience and security.
And I think that we've done
a really good job internally.
So a few of the
things that we're
doing that have simultaneously
increased our users' experience
but also increased
our security posture
would be something like,
how we onboard a user.
So unlike other
management platforms,
if you're using G Suite, G
Suite Enterprise and Chrome
Enterprise, not only do
you have the availability
to manage the device itself
by ensuring that it's
fully encrypted, the screen is
locking after a certain period
of time, and that it's booting
into an operating system
that it should be booting into
that hasn't been tampered with,
you're also able to manage
the experience from a user
perspective as well.
So as an example, on day
one, a Warby Parker employee
will start.
They'll come into the
office, they'll get the tour,
and their G Suite
user is sitting
in an organization or a unit
that has no access to anything.
They can look Gmail, they
can look at Calendar,
and they can change
some of their settings.
And we do this because if the
credentials for these newly
created accounts ever get
out, it's a big, big problem.
So we just want to silo them
off as much as possible.
The first introduction,
the first course
that somebody goes through in
their tenure at Warby Parker
is a class where they're
led through an introduction
to the hardware, and
introduction to Google,
and then enrolling
their user into
multi-factor authentication.
So within the first
few hours that they've
been with Warby Parker,
they understand,
they've been explained
to what multi-factor
is, they are more incentivized
to go home and enable
two factor authentication
on their own services.
But as a company,
because we enforce
this across the
entire domain, we're
just much more secure at
that day one crossroad.
So all of this happening
within the first couple hours,
we then moved their
user into an OU that
has more departmental
specific access,
and they have everything they
need to get off and going.
Something else that we've done,
because of the security posture
of these devices
and the policies
that we are pushing down
into Chrome, we do--
let me back up a little bit.
I mentioned, we have
a Nashville office.
It's about 350 people that
work in the Nashville area.
And 120 of those work
solely from home.
They never come into the office.
So there's a big piece of this
picture that we cannot manage,
and that is their
internet connection.
So we can push as many
policies to the device
as we want in the
user's account.
But if somebody has a
slow internet connection,
there's really nothing
we can do about that.
So typically, VPN has been
a big friction point in IT,
anything from needing
to request access
and submitting a
ticket, getting software
installed, and then
also that penalty
that it can take on your
internet connection.
Typically, everybody has a
fast internet connection.
So we really don't see
that speed penalty.
But for a lot of our
users working from home,
they might be limited to like a
megabyte down or a megabit down
and 0.5 up, so very slow
internet connection.
Adding that penalty onto
it is just untenable.
So again to loop back
around, because we're
able to manage these
devices at such granularity,
we can ensure their full disk
encryption, verified booth.
We have all agreed
internally that it's
OK to start moving some
of these private services
out into the public, making
sure that HTTPS is everywhere,
multi-factor is on.
And we can allow these
work from home users
to do what they have to do
without the need of a VPN.
Shifting gears a little
bit to talk about retail,
in our retail
environment, we probably
ship three to four laptops
to each individual store.
And these stores can range from
the number of employees from 25
on up to 50.
So it's very important as
shifts change throughout the day
to have these shared devices
within our retail stores.
We, using other
operating systems,
have tried to have this very
shared environment where
somebody comes in the
morning, they take
a laptop off the charging rack.
Somebody comes in midday,
they need to grab a laptop.
they have to do front of
house back to house duties.
There was a laptop assignment
where like two to three
people were assigned to
each individual laptop.
This caused a lot of issues.
So we were able to replace
those with Chrome OS and Chrome
devices because of that out
of the box shared experience
while maintaining this
full disk encryption,
screen lock after
about a minute.
Keep in mind that these
associates are interacting
with systems that touch PHI.
So everything that we do has to
be very mindful around keeping
within HIPAA compliance.
So that's really
allowed us to, again,
keep a very low number of
laptops out in the wild
and have that shared
experience as well,
because anybody with
a Warby Parker account
can authenticate.
So while we're
doing this, we also
have to be very aware of these
three big threat vectors that
are going on right now.
And as we get around
solving for one,
the others is just move
into the back of our head
until it comes in
shoulder taps us and says,
they want to exploit.
You need to do all these things.
So Warby Parker, kind of being
born in the era of like SAS
based services, malware has
always kind of been top of mind
.
And with the ability to
block any kind of potentially
nefarious extensions, something
that could potentially
be exfiltrating data,
anything that kind of bubbles
up, any kind of security alert
that our legal team may come
across their plate and
they request that we block
these extensions has been very,
very helpful, very beneficial.
And also, when it
comes to malware,
because everything is
siloed and sandboxed
into its own little realm--
each Chrome browser tab
is its own environment--
if any incident is occurring
on one individual tab,
it will not proliferate
out into the rest
and into the operating system.
As an example of something
that kind of shoulder taps
you as a day one,
there was the Chrome
exploit about a month ago
where everybody was saying this
is a zero day, you must update.
We were able to mitigate
this risk very quickly
by going into G Suite,
unpinning the operating system,
and forcing all the
devices to update.
So something like that really
saves on a lot of engineering
resources.
Credential threat kind of
goes hand in hand a little bit
with malware.
Again, we just want to make
sure that all of our devices
are running the latest
version of Chrome
and that they're
actually booting
into a version of Chrome OS
that has not been modified,
hasn't been tampered
with just to ensure
that they're coming into
our systems very securely.
And then of course,
phishing, which
is kind of the big hot topic.
I think I read yesterday
in another session
that 90% of all data leaks
start with a phishing attack.
So again ensuring that
devices are just up to date,
regularly checking in any
devices that we may use for any
kind of digital signage, making
sure that they're locked down
and cannot be interacted with as
someone may just naturally move
to one and start
checking their email.
We want to make sure that
each device has its own place
and is doing the things
that should be doing.
And we now have the
option of choosing
what flavor of multi-factor
we'd like to enforce across,
which ones we'd like to revoke.
So very recently, we can now
turn off as a SMS multi-factor
authentication.
So NEST has come out
and essentially said,
SMS is no longer secure.
It's better than nothing.
But it's still as you move
into the different levels
of different multi-factor,
the user experience
actually gets much better
as they get more secure.
So SMS being less secure, the
user experience isn't great.
You have the
Authenticator application,
which the user
experience improves
and security improves
at the same time.
You have the screen prompt
where you unlock your phone
and tap Yes.
Again, user experience
improves, security improves,
and hopefully you know
the dream at some point
is actually get U2F
tokens everywhere
where it's just a
touch of a button
and you're into that system.
So again, there's
this common thought
that as you're
increasing security,
the user experience
drops, and you
have to negotiate with yourself
and make exceptions somewhere.
But we've organically
moved into this realm where
we're increasing the user's
experience by granting them
the access they need, but
improving security by doing it
in a very smart way.
So all of this to say,
Chrome OS at Warby Parker
is the most popular
computer operating system.
We have well over 1,000 devices.
And it has helped us scale
in a very secure way.
So there's one big
achievement there.
The second big
achievement is sitting
on the BeyondCorp model,
the VPN-less model.
And it has helped us to decrease
our VPN use by close to 90%.
We certainly have teams
that still rely on it
and still need it, but we're
working on that remaining 10%.
So that is what I have
to say about that.
CHESTER LUI: So in the
event that you really
like this movie, please
visit our website
if you have any questions
on Enterprise security
as it relates to
Chrome Enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]